bonjour et l'alchimie merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france qu'est
ce qu'il faut attendre le sommet virtuel
mise à part le fait de relancer le débat
parce que de nouveaux engagements
peuvent être pris parce qu il faut
l'espérer maintenant nous devons
toujours être le plus obtenu que
possible et la réalité par contre plutôt
tendance à nous rappeler à certaines
formes de pessimistes et vous me
permettez simplement une rétrospection
sur la question de la coop 21 qui devait
être un succès dans 95 des cas avaient à
l'époque il ya cinq ans dont conclu et
signé cet accord l'objectif qui était
fixé à l'époque c'était de ne pas aller
au delà d'un seuil de 2% comme objectif
de démission d'augmentation de la
température de la planète à horizon 2020
en espérant atteindre 1,5 pour cent pour
autant la tendance actuelle nous rend
plutôt enfin nous sommes enfin je suis
pessimiste pour la simple et bonne
raison que selon l'onu on devrait déjà
être attendre vers -7% heures qu'on
compare mon 7,6 pour cent de gaz
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
d'horizon de la l'horizon de 2020 et
2030 et aujourd'hui pour atteindre les 1
vers 2 5%
malheureusement aujourd'hui au lieu
d'être sur une tendance à la baisse de
17% bon j'aime vous parlez on est sur
une augmentation à 2% donc on va être
plutôt sur un horizon à 3% pour qu'on a
mis très très loin des objectifs fixés
par la coop 21 alors objectifs sont ne
sont pas tenables où ils sont pas
suffisants je rappelle par exemple un
lierre les 27 de l'ue heures ont convenu
d'une réduction de leurs émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d'au moins 55 %
d'ici à 2030 accord d'étape et le
paraître t'arrêtes on permettait que les
intentions effectivement le côté positif
on va dire le la pour être optimiste lui
effectivement la position de la chine
qui glycol en fait elle va opter vers
une neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2060
on a eu la même tendance au niveau du
japon et de la corée du sud qui fit que
fait notre amie paix carbone en 2050 on
à l'élection nous avons maintenant eu
l'élection de joe biden aux états unis
qui est quand même
en faveur de la réintégration des états
unis dans l'accord de paris c'est vrai
parce qu'elle est question un positif
maman il fallait pas simplement d'avoir
des intentions et font office de toit
traduit par des actes au moment où on
parle même puis malgré la cause la
clause de l'accord vide on a eu des
baisses de 7% des gaz à effet de serre
la planète sur eto'o et on continue
comme ça nous allons entendre 2000 en
2024 1,5 pour cent ces deux
augmentations alors que tu étais laurie
à l'horizon 2100 on en est vraiment très
loin
et moi je suis je suis inquiet parce que
même s'il ya des bonnes intentions au
niveau des dates la traduction mais pas
la regarder la sur le divin nous avons
eu il ya des causes et ramener des
propositions de financement à hauteur de
234 milliards neuf cent trente quatre
milliards de dollars en faveur des
énergies fossiles alors que dans le même
temps le fameux vin qu'on compte
simplement temps 51 milliards
d'investissements pour les énergies
renouvelables
on est dans une langue dans le discours
complètement contradictoire
en outre étant qu'on fait le dérèglement
climatique et l'urd ans il y avait des
commentaires des prises de position
politiques de l'ensemble d'un certain
nombre d'ententes de d'état et quand on
regarde dans les fêtes en fait il n'ya
pas du tout de continuum et de cohérence
entre les affirmations politique et la
tendance our garança veut dire qu'il est
déjà trop tard selon vous ce que dit en
substance un nicolas hulot par exemple
on s'amuse de l'environnement on a
entendu également la semaine dernière
cyril dion de la convention citoyenne
pour pour le climat après l'interview
thème annuel macron accordée au média
brut il disait qu'il fallait accélérer
mais par exemple je pose la question
pour la france la france en at elle les
moyens
alors on ma tête des dans la volonté est
déjà la première - la première là où il
ya une volonté on trouve toujours la
solution quand on veut vraiment être
qu'à vraiment une volonté politique
je ne suis pas sûr je ne crois pas nous
sommes des halles à la france n'a déjà
pas respectées on est déjà un 2,7 pour
cent des plats sont des gars détecteurs
et la suite de la corrida était
également alors une litanie terre à
laquelle il faut répondre évidemment
mais également un moyen pour écarter
l'importance et la nécessité et
l'urgence des enjeux
environnementaux et unification sur la
crise du dérèglement climatique
je reste toujours positive et optimiste
parce qu'il faut l'être dans des
démarches et dans des dynamiques aussi
aussi importante
ceci étant il suffit de regarder les
courbes et les confections db2 tant
physique
oui je pense malheureusement que les
pros tard on est déjà très en retard par
rapport aux objectifs
et encore une fois les intentions fixé
par les neutralité affichée par les
neutralité carbone affiché par ses
différents et d'un coût rappelle
simplement qu aux termes de l'accord de
paris at 6 4 voici que c'est normalement
des contributions déterminées au niveau
national c'est à dire qu'en fait chaque
état doit expliquer un moyen enfin court
terme il envisage de faire pour
justement arrivé à tête bêtes des deux
émissions des gaz à effet serre au
moment où on parle
sur les 195 état s'était santé avancés
et produire ce femmes et ça me contre et
du stand déterminée au niveau national
il hante état pour être conduits sans
les 195 quid encore également des
engagements car il était prise à l'issue
de la coop 21 où les états les pays
riches étaient censés faire abonder un
fonds à hauteur de 100 milliards par an
pour aider les pays en développement
pour pouvoir en profiter et trouver les
voies et moyens pour lutter contre la
hausse de la température et pour éviter
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre il
n'y en ait pas là le groupe 1 on a
trouvé de l'argent pour pour gérer la
cible accuse de l'aco vide et la prise
de sanitaires on ne trouve pas les
moyens quand et pourquoi le on est sur
des modèles économiques anciens ont
encore avec un et une vision du monde
qui considère qu'en fait lutter contre
le changement climatique
c'est antinomique avec économique
l'équité une erreur leur salut
activement climatique et les enjeux
environnementaux son égard ont aussi été
connus
il n'y a pas de volonté il est trop tard
vous êtes non
merci là il a agi on a du mal à vous
captez un petit problème de liaison
mais on a compris votre message vous
êtes pessimiste mais vous appeler quand
même à l'optimisme
merci leila aichi je rappelle que vous
êtes spécialisé dans les problèmes
environnementaux et vous êtes ancienne
sénatrice europe ecologie les verts